that last presentation kind of really
shows my point and that all it takes is
putting a little bit of data out there
and then you see how many transactions
started to take place as a result of
that data but I'm also going to while
making it a statement I'm also more
imposing this as a question because
while it's a statement i believe and i
think a true car we've certainly seen
this play out an automotive I you know
I'd be curious on your experiences to
for those that don't know what true car
is or a ten year old company or a
marketplace that helps you buy and sell
cars yes we deal with I guess if you
want to call the Internet of Things we
help people actually move physical
assets but ultimately you know we don't
have any physical locations we don't run
dealerships we don't run manufacturing
lines or anything we simply provide data
to and from various places and that
ultimately is what is exchanged so to
give you a sense of the automotive
industry because I don't think and maybe
this probably isn't totally indicative
of all of it but to give you a sense of
what we're talking about why true car
was so exciting to me to join from all
these other things that I've done it's
just a massive marketplace when you add
it all up and I'm probably missing a few
hundred billion dollars but you're
talking about over a trillion dollars
for just the US market much less the
international markets and what my point
about data is the only marketplace if I
tease apart every single one of these
categories that we're talking about of
asset the last three should be some or
you know financing and extended
warranties should be somewhat obvious
that those are just pure data things
they're not even real physical assets in
any in any fashion a new car and used
car sales well you know most people
don't actually hand cash over to each
other so usually those are those are
based on loans and leases and future
future financial derivatives etc
accessories and equipment I suppose
depending on how much you believe your
LoJack is doing anything physically
useful for you I suggest it's purely a
data exchange so true car itself to give
you a sense of really what our footprint
is and why I use big words like
unprecedented and and everything that
everybody is presented I think there's
some pretty unprecedented stuff here but
as far as an industry like automotive
and I think some people in this room
probably know this it's probably harder
to crack than government as far as
getting at data and I think truecar
probably has the largest data footprint
having brought together obviously an
open consumer channel in our true car
brand but ultimately we have 139
partners across various things insurance
banks finance what we consider member
organizations iarp and then publishers
and then employee benefits programs all
strategically chosen for where they
actually fall in the marketplace and
obviously all are about exchanging data
to make things happen total total actual
consumer footprint is about six million
plus car shoppers and buyers so it's a
it's pretty big and then 11,000 truecar
certified dealers which if you want to
know what the US market is about 32,000
franchise dealers there's probably 40
thousand independent dealers but some of
those are pure data concepts because you
can't even find them on google maps
sometimes I'm not sure they exist but
11,000 with one third of the of the of
the actual dealer network in the US is a
pretty pretty big footprint so what do
we actually do you know when i'm talking
about exchanging all this data with
three major categories of data exchange
that i want to talk about obviously the
acquisition you know wherever the
consumer is wherever you're shopping you
know bring them into the the service
then there's this idea of conversion so
taking someone from purely being a
shopper into actual buyer or in case of
trade a traitor or whatever it is so to
to pass new car or used car and all
along the way you're getting various
data exchange is happening you select a
vehicle you you look at the marketing
materials you get pricing confidence and
valuation you get a sense of the cover
of where the dealer network is etc and
then ultimately you do end up at a
dealership to actually pick up the
vehicle and currently in the US you
really can't go direct you have to go
through a dealer I don't know if
everybody knows that but the laws are
fairly forbidding on how you can
actually operate which is sort of an
interesting hundred-year-old thing
hopefully over time will change so that
people can actually interact much more
easily but the idea is even at the
dealership there's there's a massive
data exchange that happens and I would
say this last part is where true car is
really focused on on cracking this data
exchange because I'm sure most of you
know if you've bought a car in the
United States it ends up being a fairly
blackbox affair and if we lose a lot of
data visibility as soon as you enter
that dealership but it's getting better
with mobile and more real-time event
tracking which is a good thing so you
know I'll say and I don't know again how
many people know about true car or our
place in the industry but it for a while
there we were getting dinged on the idea
of price and that we were driving price
as a race to the bottom which is simply
not actually true when you look at the
data it took on way too much credit it
turns out prices more of a meta data
point that when you when you look at
it's really just measuring a bunch of
other things that are going on so what
are those kind of things that we're
dealing with in terms of the data the
actual stuff I'm not going to read
through everything on here but the but
it's fairly it's fairly comprehensive so
in terms of the consumer experience
where we currently have 24 million
consumer profiles that we've built up
over the last 10 years of people going
through our platform in our network
we're kind of ambient Lee tracking / 116
million car shoppers we view everybody
who's of legal age and has a driver's
license of being a car shopper they're
just at a different point in the life
cycle there and then in terms of the
industry data that we see and you
probably could could question my hundred
percent thing because I don't really
believe you could ever achieve one
hundred percent of anything any
particular data set but if you
could we're probably the furthest along
so we believe we're seeing the majority
of inventories of vehicle data on
vehicles that are actually on the ground
OEM incentives so that's them giving you
a either the dealer huge consumer
discount on the car on that price
configurator and pricing data which you
saw some of that in the keynote where
when dr. wolfen brought up the actual
auto data most of that was being shown
with the the vehicle configurations and
the MSRP obviously the world goes much
deeper than that and it's just a really
gnarly ontology if you want to think
about it that way and then what what
kind of underneath all that is this idea
of what's called build data and this
will get a little more into why i say
data is the only market place build data
is actually what they put on the car so
you that fidelity of that data gets lost
very very quickly in the life cycle of
an actual vehicle so what happens in
many cases the OEM manufacturers the
vehicle they somewhere in some database
somewhere they actually type out or
whatever they do what's actually on this
vehicle obviously it got a VIN assigned
to it a vehicle identification number
and the all the cost data and everything
is based on that actual was put on the
vehicle okay the car gets shipped off to
whatever dealer it might if it has to go
through a port the port might install
options these are port installed options
they don't go back and edit the database
that the OEM to tell you what they
installed on it and then it ends up at a
dealer and again if you shop for four
cars in the US dealers also do dealer
installed options which is all very fine
and dandy I'm sure you all have bought
something with a dealer-installed option
on it the problem is the data isn't
captured consistently anywhere and the
real issue when you talk about something
like Price is that you literally cannot
print prices you cannot do it it's
illegal print prices if you're not
accurate so it's a huge problem when
when I'm telling you three points and
these aren't the only three points where
you lose sight
of the actual asset you're dealing with
and you know if you don't if you're not
keeping track of a port installed option
or a dealer option it's not like that's
a two dollar swing that could be you
know $5,000 swing then if you include
tax title and license those are all
different by different jurisdictions
different states different cities all
have their ways in which that they're
going to get money out of you and again
I think the last presentation was really
funny about how little hidden things
that are based on data twenty percent
here depending on tax surcharge those
things actually exist in droves in
automotive all over the place little
things you don't know you're paying for
that actually if you tease apart you say
what is this actually what is this what
is this has two years has grown quite a
bit i'm pretty excited about because
they think data will be the biggest data
set which over the last two years has
grown quite a bit i'm pretty excited
about because they think data grows
biggest data set which over the last two
years has grown quite a bit and i'm
pretty excited about because they think
data grows as your business grows when
you're making claims like i am we've
actually grown from about 20 gigabytes
of data to over a petabyte and a little
over two years which is fantastic and
most that data is just behavioral data
which is really interesting because i
could tell you about the ontology of the
industry which is all this who what
asset where people are located where
dealers are located but really the key
thing for what i'm talking about a
marketplace is actually who's who's
exchanging what with whom and how much
is it how much is it value that's really
the key stuff that we've been putting
together so give you a little just
because this is what this is we're
exchanging data so that you'll believe
what I'm telling you you know just a
little bit more about these data points
so we value over 200 billion possible
vehicle combinations a day it's it's a
pretty I don't even that's a rough
estimate because I don't know how to
correctly calculate every possible
option tax title license because all
that could change based on where the
vehicle moves etc we're tracking about
65 billion events every single day we
process cover a billion vehicle images
that believe we have the largest vehicle
image data set that has been highly
trained for doing vehicle recognition
just from a single image
obviously all the car by profiles all
the the vens that are moving around
every single day and ultimately beyond
the data that we're sourcing directly
from a consumer we actually have twelve
thousand different third-party data
feeds coming in that are
non-standardized and trust me this
industry is about as crazy it gets and
in terms of data formats so let's get
into my premise here a little bit which
is let's just talk about something I
think we all can kind of common sense
you know talk about what is price if you
ask people that work at a dealership or
whatever they'll give you kind of a
colloquial version is well it's whatever
someone's willing to pay for something
I'm sure you've gone to a dealer that's
your experience of price right hey well
you know how much you got well okay yeah
I get it so that's what somebody's
willing to offer in exchange for
something else ultimately for true car
if you want to you know measure the
values of things over time and be able
to predict those things etc this
definition price really is just a
historical artifact it's what what
happened in a transaction well it starts
to get a little metaphysically weird
when you start thinking about markets
stock markets and vehicle markets and
things like this and I could talk about
weirder markets like selling compute
cycles and things like that where a
price becomes very bizarre and how you
actually quantify and tie it to
something in the real world so when we
say price before a transaction occurs
what are we really talking about and I I
don't quite have a great definition for
this I think the definition comes out
through an experience with the data it's
probably different for each one of us
which I know again is a very bizarre
notion but the idea here is that you
know we give you if you've ever been on
true card and you saw it in an earlier
slide where we give you a little bit of
distribution of the transaction prices
that happened in your local area for
that car that you are looking at you
know we've synthesized a bunch of data
we've imputed a bunch of things and
ultimately we say look this is this is
these are the transactions that have
happened in your area so we're not
saying this is the exact price you
should pay instead we're saying look it
should be in this range somewhere so it
is sort of putting guardrails on
actually
but what these prices should be I don't
know exactly how you want to define that
and I think dealers will have a
different perception of that then OEM
people and to give you a sense of that
MSRP I get into all these discussions
with people because again I go what is
an MSRP well that's a suggested price of
course the OEMs MSRP suggested price is
much higher than you know say the
consumers suggested retail price which
right you know so you're really what
you're trying to do in these data
exchanges bring everybody closer right
and that's really the role of true car
let's get everybody's expectation a
little more line so that there's less
stress and then ultimately you know I
even call into question the definition
of someone when you go to the dealership
it's it's rarely in fact i think the
stat is it's 75 percent of people go to
the dealership with another person it's
called a third basement in the industry
and they really hate that because
usually you bring a negotiator with you
because you know you know you're going
to get ganged up on or whatever it is
and so you bring a third party usually
it's your pal or someone that's
convinced you they're really good at
negotiating whether that's true or not
so when you're dealing with someone the
dealer is actually prepared to deal with
the third basement not the actual person
who's going to be signing the papers
then when you think about the someone
that the papers and what I mean by
papers is the financial information the
loan or the least or whatever that
definition of a someone is very
different than that someone who's
sitting across the table from the dealer
that someone is a number or a set of
numbers a risk analysis of whether this
person can pay for this car etc etc and
if you're wondering you know if if
that's me making that stuff up no it has
real value that's you know hundreds of
billions of dollars go into that
assessment of that person it has nothing
to do with that actual person sitting at
the table that's the insurance risk
models and things like that so really
when you're talking about the final
value of a deal it's actually data
that's been exchanged so you know kind
of how do we think about putting this
all together a couple simple statements
I suppose but hopefully they're they're
meaningful the more data the more that
we can determine again I don't think we
can achieve a hundred percent perfection
so that's why price
is not to me a discreet you get the
answer right here it is it's much more
of a moving target but you can be more
confident in that price more confident
in all these exchanges the more data
that you have I think it goes back to
one of the earlier talks today where the
question came up about data truth versus
the shades of grey and I really
personally believe and I've seen it
through true car that really everything
is a shade of gray I think about the
exoplanet stuff and things like that and
I think we can say those are exoplanets
but until we visit the planet we don't
really know how accurate our assessment
is and I think this is to my point in
here so we really just believe the more
you accumulate the more we can determine
price is just one one data point but
there's a lot that goes in there and i
kind of measure and maybe this is weird
and some of my Wolfram alumni background
but I'm measuring our ability to
determine things by how much data we
have I can't quite come up with a better
measure than that so right now we have
about a petabyte I don't think that's
enough to do everything we want to do
but it's certainly growing and that's
good and then if you want to think about
it and I think other people have
mentioned other industries but really
every industry is supported by the data
exchange can't I think that last talk
was great how many weird little things
change simply because you publish
descriptive statistics and you you
really changed materially taxicabs
annual salaries and things like that
simply by publishing data and it really
is the thing that moves things then you
get into this so let's extend this a
little bit because I was having a
conversation at lunch with a couple
people it was interesting because you
know the question is always can you ever
get to a hundred percent data fidelity
and data clarity on these thing I think
the answer is no because as soon as you
think you got there something changes
even in industry 100 years old with
these little cars driving around mapping
the world and ultimately you know I
don't know if it's google but enough
people will will send out these cars
there self-driving if you believe that's
even possible I don't know if it is I'm
not yet ready to get in one and trust my
life to that little thing driving around
but when if I could make the case that
was very straightforward than the
metaphysical things I was saying
there's nothing more data-driven that i
can think of than that thing and you
inside of it letting it drive you around
the world this changes the entire
automotive market if this becomes a
major mode of transportation for obvious
reasons all those categories of the
trillion dollars is and there I mean
insurance is based on the idea of the
person driving the car so now I don't
know where insurance as a business
actually goes in this world we've
already seen some of that disruption how
do you actually insure an uber driver
and a car that's being employed in the
use of uber I think it's a super it's a
super weird thing and luckily you know
here's my whole self fulfilling premise
the answer these questions are only a
mountain more data so I really feel like
we have to build the biggest data
platform again another proof point
normal how many people know this but
three OEMs just got together and spent
three billion dollars to buy the Nokia
Maps division which is a really
interesting thing when you think about
OMS they think they realized we can't
let Google and Apple have all the data
we're going to have to start owning all
this mapping data or self if this is the
reality of where cars are going maybe
I'm miss reading that but I thought that
was a very expensive purchase of a pure
data asset so a couple points on this to
kind of tie it all together and these
are just these are products obviously
the people in here are familiar with but
but they're really to the point that I'm
trying to tie everything to that you got
to get this idea that the data you gotta
have enough data to be material you got
to be able to identify what you're
dealing with and however you want to say
that I think the last two talks ago kind
of talked about classification and
different ways of doing that and then
ultimately you got to get you got to
have the context all of these are data
concepts but I think these things really
only come together and fulfill the
premise I'm saying about data is a
marketplace when you have those three
those three things in place and I think
we're going to see more and more of
these I don't know what you call these
things because they're not pure
programming they're not pure data
there's some weird hybrid thingy that
sits in the middle of them and I think
that's why we've you know my experience
from spending the first year of Wolfram
Alpha trying to talk to people
through is a very difficult system to
talk to an average business about even
what I'm saying with true car try
explaining what I'm trying to build a
true car to a dealer who's been selling
cars for 30 years they don't exactly
think of what they're selling is is a
data exchange so you know if I were to
bring it all around and I could just
keep saying that this is a very self
recursive cycle here where every
industry has many conclusive data points
until they aren't conclusive then they
go exploit new opportunities and this
just keeps feeding itself over and over
and over again anything many of you are
in those kind of businesses or those
organizations so obvious examples you
know where it's just obvious that this
is a pure data exchange and I could go
on to state you know things like Amazon
is a great example to me of like you
start by selling books you end up
building the world's biggest cloud
platform you end up making seven billion
dollars doing that you end up running
drone businesses now and shooting
rockets into space you know amazon can
only do that because it ultimately was a
giant date of business that we're all
giving our data to every single day etc
so I could keep pulling examples out
like this so questions about anything I
don't know if I've made the case I hope
I've asked the question that in the end
I think if it's not true today that
every marketplace is a data marketplace
I'm pretty certain that's mostly what
we're all going to be exchanging in a
very obvious way